now there comes a point in every game
developments life where content creators
artists and designers become very
frustrated with the engineer's on a
project you see most novice engineers
for game dev when adding artwork and
content into a game will usually hard
code the path references to assets which
means that if a designer an artist wants
to change that data they have to go talk
to an engineer first which engineers
usually have a backlog of 30 to 60 days
worth of tasks kind of slowing down the
entire project more experienced
engineers know how to avoid this and
actually move themselves towards a
concept of data-driven design a concept
which allows non-engineers to
effectively change the execution of the
flow and the assets in the game without
ever having to talk to an engineer
basically this works by providing some
sort of simplistic data file outside of
the game code a text file XML JSON
something that the designers in the
artist can quickly iterate on without
having to talk to anybody in the pit
case in point let's say a designer and
an artist need to find the optimal
animation time for some kick maneuver on
a 2d fighting game well it'd be great if
they could actually sit at the desk and
try different variations of art creation
and timing without actually having to go
talk to an engineer to change the frames
that are referenced most games these
days actually have a huge backbone of
data-driven design of course you end up
in a very very weird position is that if
you have too much data driven design you
actually become a slave to it in the
sense that most of your code exists out
of there so changing small situations
becomes very very difficult you actually
have to bring an engineer back in so
walk that line very finely you want to
be just data-driven enough that it makes
sense and everyone can get their job
done but not so much that actually
causes problems to your larger
architecture